okay Daniel here we sit days before the
big day for you how are you feeling as
you're getting ready
um well I'm I'm probably feeling a
mixture of uh nervous and uh excited uh
for what's been you know an 18-month
journey and finally getting to unveil uh
all of these great uh new product
updates so so what excites you most
because people looking at the platform
would say I've used Spotify it seems to
be working fine but you looked at it and
you thought what well you know we hear
time and time again the same things both
from consumers and creators so from
consumers
we hear you know help me find great new
music help me find great new content and
help help me find great ways to connect
with my favorite artists and from the
artist side it has always helped me grow
my audience helped me engage with my
audience and help me monetize this
audience and
um we thought long and hard about what
we could do to develop the platform
further and and one of those ways is
obviously this now re-designed Spotify
that I think delivers on both the
consumer side of the needs and the
Creator side of the need as well you
said Spotify is the best home for
creators you can establish your career
and where the world can be inspired by
your creativity but this is my favorite
line a place where you can Thrive and
grow no matter what stage you're at I
could see people sitting at home
thinking Daniel I have some ideas yeah
what do you mean by a place where you
can Thrive and grow no matter what stage
you're at well I I think it's important
that Spotify is uh the Creator's home
and we're really open for business for
all creators of all sizes whether you're
just starting out or whether you're
already a well-established Creator and
just wants more Avenues to reach new
audiences and engage and monetize that
art and so
um the real thing here is we're
providing tools and opportunities for
creators even and from when they're
young and starting out all the way up to
super well established but what makes
you different Daniel than the other kids
in the class because you're not the only
content creators you're not the only
Music Choice music platforms that people
have What Makes You Different well
um again we're an experience that's
focused on deep engagement and listening
but also a very big part of what we're
focusing on as well is for people who
aspire to be professional or are already
professional so we're not the place
perhaps where you connect with friends
or or Express uh you know a funny video
but we are a place where you can share
your art you can engage with fans and
you can monetize that art better
let's talk about the monetize part
because you know everybody I know likes
to make money everybody myself included
So when you say monetize what does that
mean
well
um how does that work yeah so depending
on if you're a musician or a podcasters
you have everything from the opportunity
here or participating in our revenue
streams one of them is of course
advertising and if you're a musician you
can also participate in our subscription
programs as well where we pay out over
70 percent of the revenue back to rights
holders like you know labels and
Publishers
amongst others but let's pick up on that
Daniel because still it's still been an
ongoing criticism about Spotify that the
artists don't get what they deserve that
the artists are not paid enough what do
you say to that that seems to have been
a running criticism from the very
beginning with Spotify yeah and I I
think what was probably fair in
hindsight is this is a new model and a
quite a dramatic shift from how the
music industry worked before and we
certainly could have done a much better
job explaining what streaming is and how
it worked but the last few years we've
really amped up on our transparency and
we have a program now called loud and
clear that really sets the record
straight and we have some new numbers
that we're updating today so if you look
back and you think about Spotify from
the origin up until today we paid out
now almost 40 billion dollars back to
the music industry and we're the number
one Revenue generator for the entire
recorded music industry at this point
wow and then in addition to that as I
mentioned over 70 cents on each dollar
or about 70 cents on each dollar goes
back to that music industry as well so I
feel like it is working and it's working
on a scale that is never worked on
before where more artists big and young
alike are succeeding so just one stack
which I think is interesting so the
artists that are making more than a
million dollars a year and the artists
that are making over 10 000 dollars a
year that number has more than doubled
in the last five years so more and more
artists are finding success than ever
before well why do people still think
many people still think Spotify doesn't
pay the artist who should they direct
their their inquiries too if not to you
at Spotify yeah well technically it is
true that we don't pay artists directly
um so what we do is we pay all the
rights holders we pay them exactly
record labels record labels but also the
music Publishers so sometimes when I sit
down with artists
um and and they sort of tell me
um I didn't get paid yeah as an example
it's it's very hard because again they
have their Deals they have their their
deals with their record companies and
their deals with their Publishers
Etc and what Spotify does is we pay out
to those record companies and these
Publishers and and don't know what
individual deals these artists may have
so is it fair to say if artists have a
complaint about not getting paid it
shouldn't be directed at Spotify it
should be directed as the record labels
well again you know we're happy
obviously to talk to any individual
creator that is asking about payouts and
of course they should also talk to their
record companies and and music
Publishers as well what do you think
about Drake's recent proposal he said he
had I think 75 billion streams or
something gazillion streams yeah and he
said you know when you're when you're at
that level maybe they should be paid
like athletes you know that it's they
should get bonuses is that something
that you subscribe to
um I I don't know I that I've seen that
proposal what he proposes but um again
many of the artists that are of the
Drake statures obviously have very
different type of deals than maybe an
artist that's starting out but again
those are deals that they make with
their record companies and Publishers on
spotify's part it's actually all the
same for us we pay just as much if it's
3 take us if it is an up-and-coming
artist as well does it frustrate you
that people sometimes blame Spotify well
or do you think that just comes with the
territory I I think it comes with a
territory uh to a certain extent and
then again where I take responsibility
is I should have spent a lot more time
up front
um trying to be more transparent and
communicate this and it's a complex
subject and it's not easy because
there's many facets to this as I said
we're paying out you know a percentage
of our Revenue that goes through lots of
different uh royalty holders and that in
turn then gets divided up to artists Etc
so it's a complex topic but I wish I
would have handled it up front and it's
very hard to change a narrative once
that narrative has established itself
that's I guess the lesson learned from
my side when we're talking about
putting more money in artist Pockets
what do you you have other ways of doing
that other than just paying them yeah so
I mean
um I I think that the future
um of Spotify will be one where
um all creators will not just just buy
just one Revenue model but where they
can actually build their home and have
multiple Revenue models so if you think
about it from a music artist point of
view today you know again the recorded
music is one Revenue source that they
have but they also have live touring
which is a major one for them and they
have merch with t-shirts and stuff I buy
a t-shirt at every con every concert
yeah yeah
um and and so
um what we have Spotify facilitates that
yeah we we're facilitating that and
we're making it easier and easier so
that for instance if you're a fan of a
certain artist Harry Styles Harry Styles
we would suggest Beyonce yeah and
Beyonce we would suggest when either of
those are close enough to you and you
can basically go straight from there and
buy a concert tickets but we would also
be able to say hey Gail you're actually
the top one percent uh listener of
Beyonce so we might be able to give you
special access here to some tickets and
that allows both a greater artist
experience right because they want to
make sure their top fans have a better
experience but they also want an
engagement for the for the fans as well
yeah and it's a nice treat you know if
you're a super fan that you get treated
a little bit differently so we're
allowing for that sort of interaction
between artists and fans that happen in
more ways than one and more Revenue
models also for creators to be able to
sustain their their Artistic Endeavors
the thing that can't be disputed is the
number of users that Spotify has you
have you have to be doing the hula
around here about your latest numbers
what are they yeah so uh where we
announced today that we've passed over
half a billion users uh and uh that's
that's a milestone that I'm incredibly
proud of I'm proud of the team for
achieving and kind of been a dream ever
since since we started out Spotify back
in the day I know but Daniel let's just
let's just take a pause on that for just
a second
half a billion users what does that mean
to you I mean that number is so big it's
like we should have a head exploding
Emoji over your head yeah over your head
right now yeah what does that mean to
you personally and professionally it
it's it's crazy to make it
um to to to even fathom and understand
uh that number but uh what I will tell
you Gail is
um in the early days of Spotify when we
looked at what the potential one day
would be the biggest platforms on the
internet back in that time had about a
half a billion users so we the big harry
audacious goal we set out for ourselves
is what if one day uh we could be there
too uh and it's surreal and quite crazy
to imagine we're now here and now
obviously being the Restless
entrepreneur that I am we've then
extended that goal to now get to a
billion people uh before 2030 so that's
what we're we're chasing at the moment
are you a Restless entrepreneur is that
how you see yourself
yeah I mean
um I think I'm probably my own toughest
critic
um and uh
the people closest to me would probably
say I'm never satisfied which is both a
blessing and a curse I think so it's
it's one of those things that I'm trying
to reflect on much more uh having you
know turned 40 and trying to be more
mature in my life to to celebrate
successes especially the team successes
um a lot more than perhaps I've done in
the past well Daniel you started this
company when you were 22 you're now 40.
but at 22 what were your Visions what
were your dreams of 22. you clearly were
a disrupter back then what were you
thinking well I
um
like most 22 year olds I thought I could
take on the world and beat it and didn't
think uh didn't understand why everyone
was uh you know uh so slow and hadn't
done what I already had imagined so you
have uh perhaps too much confidence in
your own abilities and too little
understanding about the rest of the
world but that is quite often a
successful
attribute when you think about
entrepreneurs is if you've known how
hard things would have been you probably
would have never done it so not actually
knowing probably saved me many times
um and and then I think uh for me it's
like
you know when it came to music
um I felt like I was already living in
the future because Sweden at that time
we had a super fast Broadband
connectivity
um we had you know probably 10 megabits
internet connections which is now
commonplace
but I had that 1997 in my own house and
um so what I was consuming was obviously
lots of content but the services weren't
around to do that and so it was kind of
obvious to me that something like a
Spotify would exist in the world
and I couldn't figure out why that
hadn't happened and with so much piracy
in the world it was obvious to me that
you couldn't fight piracy by suing your
customers which is what the music
industry was doing at that time but you
had to build something that was better
than piracy
um and and
um you know that was really the kind of
inspiration of spotify and
um you know there are some entrepreneurs
that magically
um just can come up with entirely New
Concepts and ideas I'm I wish I was that
but I'm not that type of person but I am
the person that can take something and
know intuitively how I can make it
better and
um and it was just so clear to me it was
like you know this is obvious and this
is the way it should work and that's
what I built on well it was obvious to
you but at 22 people it's not like they
said Daniel Eck what a great idea people
said free music are you crazy streaming
yeah get out of here in fact you were
rejected pretty soundly in the beginning
yeah did you ever think about quitting
many times did you many many many times
it was rough I mean the first two and a
half years
um it was just constant rejection after
rejection after rejection and there was
many times when I wanted to give up
um along the way but
um
I I don't even know why I kept going but
I think it was kind of this idea that uh
if we could pull it off it would be uh
amazing and then you know I again I I
come back to what I said earlier I think
um I I don't know of a single
entrepreneur that
um if if you would go back to them now
and ask them if you knew everything you
know now would you do it again then the
answer certainly for me but I think for
unilaterally for all entrepreneurs I've
been talking to has been like no because
it's so hard there's it's such an
emotional roller coaster up and down up
and down it never stops it's just up and
down you wouldn't do it again
um
this way
no I'm not I'm not sure to be honest
it's not because it's not been worth it
it's been the most gratifying thing I've
ever done in my life besides my kids but
um and your wife and my wife she's
lovely yes yes
um but but it's it's
it's not for the faint-hearted and it's
the sacrifices you're doing as well all
the friends birthdays all the uh
parent-teacher conferences all the
normal things you frankly have to uh you
know prioritize work over uh that's hard
and you're constantly living with that
thing where uh at any moment there's a
phone call there's a crisis going on
there's something you need to do and
that's that's hard you said they're like
what did you describe near death what
did you say for Tech entrepreneurs yeah
yeah yeah so so I have this saying
um you know I I
as a part of learning and developing
myself in my craft which is you know
being an entrepreneur being a CEO I I
study other companies and study you know
the great companies the great
entrepreneurs through history and
um you know I I haven't yet come across
one of these brilliant companies that
haven't had at least three near death
experiences as a company and so
oftentimes when when I'm asked by other
Founders and they're going through a
rough patch I tell them not to try to
avoid the problems but actually to
celebrate the problems because again
that problems means overcoming those
problems means you're creating a lot of
value in the end and and that's my
mental trick to kind of allow me to keep
going and keep tackling these hard
issues as their their arising on the
horizon so celebrating problems okay
let's go there with Joe Rogan because
you you can't get the success you have
without having some bumps along the way
and we could certainly describe Joe
Rogan as a big old bump you know there
were many people that were very
disappointed and outraged that he was
still allowed to remain on your platform
he's very controversial as you know he's
accused of saying some anti-semitic
things misinformation
how did you navigate that what was your
thought process in deciding what you
were going to do and how you were going
to handle Joe Rogan
yeah I mean
it's
it's never easy right and we've had
actually many of these stories with
great artists as well around uh in the
history where some artists pulled out
and then subsequently came back and so
on so uh it's never an easy thing and
every situation is quite unique but I
think it's important to put this one in
particular in contexts
um because we were at the height of a
global pandemic and obviously people
around the world were really scared
about the implications on their safety
and health but also perhaps family
members and what would happen to the
economy there were a lot of things that
were fluctuating at that very moment
and um
as as I was dealing with this situation
I was getting advice or left in center
and I remember it pretty vividly because
I think I was uh staying up probably for
about three or four uh
nights in a row and not getting much
sleep at all and and eventually I I
ended up taking a nine hour sleep just
in order to think more clearly and clear
your head maybe yeah clear my head and
kind of get back to it and and it it
wasn't a quick decision by any means but
what I what I sort of centered around
was one around this particular issue
the coveted thing it was portrayed us
this very black and white issue and yet
where I come from Europe and Sweden in
particular if you take something as uh
as child vaccinations for instance
in most of Europe for instance that was
not recommended whereas in America it
was kind of like obvious that you needed
to vaccinate your children and Spotify
is a global platform right and so I I
highlight this because even the public
experts safety experts around the world
weren't in agreement about what to do
and so this wasn't a black and white
issue this was very much a gray issue
where people had very strong views on
one side of the island on the other side
of the aisle Etc
and
um you know as I was looking at this and
I was looking at this as very much a
developing situation I had to think
about that but I also had to think about
and re-center myself around what kind of
platform do we want to be and I was
obviously getting advice from from
everywhere around it and the most
important Insight I had is I had to be
able to be true to myself and I felt
like I had to be able to live with this
decision knowing
um I it couldn't just be a smart
decision it had to be a decision I could
stand by on a personal grounds as well
and
um where I centered around round is that
I went back to our core values as a
platform Spotify is a place where we
allow more speech we allow a huge
diversity of voices from all over the
world around it there are lots of things
that are controversial you know take for
instance hip-hop music where the lyrics
in hip-hop could be highly controversial
as well depending on who's listening to
it and this doesn't mean that I agree
with everything that someone says on the
platform I don't there are many things
that I find offensive as I'm sure to you
personally yeah yeah and as I'm sure you
do too but it's important to me that we
have our guidelines and those guidelines
we try to apply unilaterally across the
board and so as we're evaluating a Rogan
versus someone else the big question
just comes down to is this violating our
terms of service and if it was it should
be taken down and if it wasn't it sure
may not and it's it's a quite simple
principle but sometimes you get sort of
stuck on this because Rogan is the
world's number one podcaster right but
it was important to me that he follows
the same rules that we have for everyone
else and that this particular moment and
heated debate
couldn't impact that principle
and values that we had as platform but
he's recently been called out by the
Anti-Defamation League for making yet
another anti-semitic comment on the
platform do you consider some of the
things he says to be anti-Semitic and if
so how do you reconcile that on your
platform yeah again
um I I find a lot of things uh that you
know well I I would say I I find that
common in particular highly offensive
and there are a lot of things that I
disagree with that Joe Rogan and lots of
other voices are saying on our platform
as well but I come back to it is this
violating our terms of service and odd
and if it is then we take it down and if
you take
um
um anti-semitic comments we've taken
down thousands of podcasts uh that have
violated our our our platform rules and
in the broader con context there's
probably hundreds of thousands of
episodes that are violating other terms
of service as well so we do take that
very seriously we're looking at each and
every one of these individual episodes
and look at if it's violating our our
terms of service or not but the
important part here is it's not what I
find offensive the ghost or doesn't go
there are lots of things that I don't
like and that I disagree with by other
podcasters as well we evaluate each and
every episode
um according to that policy and we have
experts and a safety advisory Council
that take those actions so it's not me
personally that take those actions but
it's that group with experts from all
sectors uh really that that make those
decisions around each and every time and
but because you're the face Daniel no
one says you know the experts say it's
it's directly attributed to you that's
yeah that's the thinking in the public
and I understand that but I think it's
really important that this isn't just
um a decision that's made by me uh it is
made by a diverse group of people too
with with
um a varied perspective because again
I'm I'm a guy white guy from Sweden I
can't know the intricate details of
every cultural group all over the world
too so we have a very broad team of
experts that have been working these
fields for decades that make these
decisions and they evaluate it and the
same rules apply to Joe Rogan as it
would to any other podcaster but how do
you handle the Daniel when some of your
own employees and the audience at large
says Daniel this is too much too too far
you have to do something how do you
personally handle that when people are
screaming in the streets they're
offended they're upset with him they're
upset with you yeah they're upset with
the platform you know what do you do it
it it's it's obviously never fun I mean
it's much easier to be well liked by
everyone than uh to have people uh be
very upset and think you're doing the
wrong things so that's a tough thing you
have to work on with yourself but
I guess what I'm trying to say to you
Gail is that it's never as one-sided as
it gets portrayed because as as much as
people are disagreeing with decisions
I'm getting a 10x uh the amount of that
sometimes on the other side too that are
agreeing with these things uh as well
and we have a platform where we're live
in 184 countries and territories not all
of them share the same culture or the
same values so there are lots of voices
all over the world that are talking
about everything under the sun and it's
not just in podcasting but the same is
true in music too there are lots of
lyrics that I find highly offensive as
well but the big thing is that we come
back to whether is this violating our
policies or not and if it is no matter
if you're Rogan or another major artist
we will take it down and if it's not
then it will remain up because we
believe that more speech is actually
gonna
Propel our society forward and not
silencing voices do you have to take
your own personal inventory during those
times Daniel how what you Daniel Eck
believe do you have to do that for
yourself
yeah I mean it's it's tough as I said
there are lots of things that I disagree
with at some time but that's why I think
it's so important to take that time to
reflect to think and I think what I keep
coming back to like in the Rogan
scenario is I believe in our mission as
a company right and I believe in why
we're here and I love the fact that
there are these diverse uh voices and if
you go back in history you know
um again and study the true grades
wherever they were the Copernicus of the
world were the great inventors many of
their ideas were highly offensive at
that time too and we take them for
granted too when when the person came
along who said hey the Earth is around
they wanted to burn him on a cross
because everyone thought the world was
flat but it's these ideas too I think
that that debate is important that
doesn't mean everything goes just to be
very clear yeah that's why you know we
have these guidelines where where if
people are you know subjecting other
people to harm we do take action but I
think it is important that we are a
place that allows a lot of diverse
voices to be able to express themselves
to be able to communicate through ART
and some are doing it through using
parody some are doing it being very
serious some are doing it through music
some are doing it through books now and
some are doing it through a podcast and
we're we're a place for all of that and
I I recenter around that I'm I'm proud
of what we're doing and and the impact
we have on the world it's reported that
his contract is up at the end of this
year will he be renewed
well what I can say is
um the contract of believe has uh some
more time to go than that so we'll we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it have
have you ever had to talk to him and say
Hey Joe you need to tone it down a bit
have you ever done that or you stay out
of that too I try to mostly stay out of
it I I've had conversations with them
and I find them to be really thoughtful
I find him to try to learn from
reactions from people and try to evolve
his stance too but I think he's also
grappling with this fact of you know he
went from being sort of just a podcast
having fun on the side to now being one
of the world's largest voices on all
sorts of topics and he mostly did this
um
to satisfy his own curiosity and have
interesting conversations for himself
and he's now realizing he's uh having
huge impact in the world and that's
something he's got to be true to himself
and evolve his own voice and that comes
with great responsibility yeah yeah you
know when you say that you have 500
million listeners yet there are still
reports that Spotify is not profitable
how is that possible because the company
is hugely successful you were on the
billionaires so you're doing all right
when it comes to your own finances but
the company still is not profitable does
that trouble you are you worried and why
is it not profitable
um I'm not really worried about it
because it's really within our control
so if we didn't invest as much in that
future success as we have been these
past few years we would turn a profit so
it's really a function of us reinvesting
in growing and that growth of course
gets us to the half a billion and over
200 million paying customers which then
helps the music industry free and then
long term builds a great business so
that's how we've been focused on just
reinvesting and so we can see it was a
deliberate Choice Daniel you go for
growth over profitability true it was
very much a deliberate
um
Target for us and what we said at our
investor date which we had in June of
last year was that 2022 would be the
last year where we would pursue uh
growth over profitability and I'll bet
investors like hearing that yeah they
they do so they're happy to hear that
and uh now in 2023 and going forward we
will focus more on profitability while
still growing do you have any doubt that
you can be profitable as you sit here
today no I don't because it's really
within our control again the company is
growing nicely as it is and as we get
leverage I.E spend less on marketing uh
spend less on uh you know just rapidly
growing our finance functions legal
functions all those things then we'll
eventually become profitable through
covid did you what did you learn good
and bad through code did it allow the
company to Pivot in such a way that you
didn't think possible yeah I think that
there were lots of lessons learn but I I
don't think we've ever seen consumer
habits change as fast in in history as
they were doing covet right because we
all had to we all had to if you know
people never try to order online before
had to all of a sudden order online
right and you know again normally
um for instance with Spotify one of the
big places that people listen to Spotify
was in the car but since people no
longer commuted to work that disappeared
and instead people started consuming in
their home and even the kind of contents
people were consuming was different we
saw mindfulness Rising
um as a very big thing people were
focusing on and then
um you know daily news shows as an
example in the beginning did really well
but in the end people got tired of
hearing the Doomsday scenarios painted
out and went from mindfulness instead
there were lots and lots of consumer
habits that changed in a very very short
period of time let's talk about the the
changes with Spotify when people wake up
very soon this week and they go to
Spotify it will look different for them
yeah how so
and what did it take for you to say we
need to be different because but what
will they see that's different well so
so uh there's a number of new updates
um uh that were announcing really today
um one of them is an entirely new home
feed so uh completely redesigned from
the ground up you'll see Spotify I think
come alive you're going to see a lot
more interactive content you're going to
see clips of content that might be
really interesting to you that's being
recommended to you and you're going to
be able to see visual components for
instance clips and videos that people
are uploading with that content too
we'll be able to scroll then you're
going to be able to scroll scroll
through those clips to find interesting
content for you so that's the first
change the second big change we actually
announced already two weeks ago but
we're rolling it out to more people is
what we call AI DJ very cool uh which is
super already got mine yeah that's
amazing yeah it's my favorite too and
what do you Alias is imagine having like
your own personal DJ that knows your
music taste knows uh what kind of music
you're liking and is able to give you
context around why you're hearing that
songs and putting together the perfect
uh sort of Music AI DJ does not sound
like a robot it sounds like a real
person yes do you do that on purpose yes
we did we we did not do that on for a
purpose and and in fact it's actually a
real person too and what do you mean
yeah so so it's built on a real live
individual uh his name is we call him X
Xavier so he's a Spotify employee oh
he's an employee yeah that's that's been
around for forever uh we used him for
meet him yeah well we'll make sure I
have a picture in my head of what he
looks like so I'm curious okay go ahead
yeah go ahead um he's a real person he's
a real person and it started out because
he he were emceeing a lot of our
internal events here and
um you know it kind of dawned upon us
that hey having him be our personal DJ
wouldn't that be cool and then we were
playing around with it for the beta and
we loved it so much that we asked him if
it was okay uh to actually use and did
he say hmm yes yeah he was super excited
he didn't have to twist his arm because
it's such a fun job I I agree I agree
with you but uh you know it was
important that he was okay with it yes
and uh we we uh we had fun while doing
it and it's it's it it's amazing because
this version of X now this AI DJ is
talking about all sorts of things that
the real life ex never said yeah right
and that's the amazing thing now because
it is making it personal to you Gail yes
but it's like he knows me looking at my
feed and he makes very good
recommendations exactly right and and uh
it's it's funny because I was talking to
him before about this and now people
come up to him uh and tell him uh like
oh you recommended such amazing music
and obviously he has no idea because he
never said those things in in real life
so it's funny to see how we're all kind
of getting confused about uh what's
happening in the background but it's an
amazing product that I can't wait for
people to try out the AI technology does
it scare you in any way
um it it does and it doesn't
um so I I think on a broader scale uh it
is it is kind of crazy to imagine
um what the world may look like in five
or ten years if we go to what people
call AGI artificial general intelligence
which basically means that you have an
AI that might be smarter than any human
alive right
um so that's kind of daunting to think
about what the consequences might be for
Humanity
um as we're there and I think we have to
be very careful about it but at the same
time uh on the other side it's also so
obvious that AI can help so much by
making
um you know both experiences better and
easier for all of us to deal with and
that's pretty much in every single field
did you make the scrolling and the
videos because of tick tock were you
looking at Tick Tock going we got to do
something about this well we've got to
change with the program was that part of
it well it wasn't so much around a
specific
um sort of platform but rather kind of
looking at what Young consumers do one
of the big things for me is you have to
live in the future and for me the future
is always uh the young people what are
they doing in various cultures and I
would say as an industry every few years
um
in the industry someone brings something
out from a design perspective that's
just much much better way for people to
interact with it and um you know snap
for instance did that with stories and
now almost every platform has stories
and Tick Tock obviously did that with
their Discovery feed as well so we're
definitely taking inspiration from that
but we're adding a unique Spotify Twist
on a tube so I don't want people to
think that we're making this to be like
Tick Tock we're making it to be a much
more interactive Spotify do you think a
lot about the future is that how your
brain works you think about the future
um I I don't know that I that I'm sort
of forcing myself to think about the
future per se but I'm constantly
thinking about how
how you know what people are doing I'm
observing uh what people are doing and
I'm constantly thinking about how one
can improve those things
um and and in doing so you kind of tend
to live in the future anyway because
most of those things
um may be there um you know there's I
think it was Bill Gates who said it but
but it's a quote I like very much and he
says that the the future is already here
it's just not evenly distributed
and I believe in that a lot so I think
you can can if you're looking at what
people are doing around the world I
think in many cases you already see the
future we just all haven't experienced
it yet and
um
that's my source of inspiration as I
think about Innovation how important are
podcasts to the Spotify platform
it's it's it's really huge Gale
um you know over music no it's not over
music I mean
um my background and where we started
was music and it's always going to be
our core
um but it's a huge way because
um one of the things that I realized as
well is that they're additive to each
other it's not instead of
um you know if you think about it like
what would happen if you in the car only
had music and no talk
um well you know people are going to ask
about the weather they're going to ask
about traffic report they're going to
ask about news they're going to ask
about a bunch of different things and so
what we realized is that these two
things together actually means people
will spend more time on music and more
time on talk
and we could see that immediately from
when we launched it too so so it's
critical I think going forward
that we have both of these amazing
classes of creators on the platform so
are you musically inclined yeah I'm I'm
musically inclined for sure I I'm I
started playing guitar when I was like
four or five so you can play the guitar
okay yeah so so that's my kind of main
instrument uh and I love music but the
truth is I just wasn't good enough to
make it in music that's the reality but
that doesn't mean that I don't love it
and uh for me you know when I started
Spotify
um my dream was to be able to uh combine
my two big loves which is technology and
computers on the one hand and music and
that's why I started doing Spotify it
wasn't because it was this sort of great
business idea music and Technology yeah
yeah because you were a big coder that's
your your huge coder I mean there's a
story about you hacking the high school
computers is that true uh it's probably
true probably what were you looking for
what were you looking for did you do
just do it for the hell of it the fun of
it yeah it was like fun to prank to
teachers because you could get sort of
like fart sounds out of the computers
and fart sounds yeah you know Daniel
that's so mature and so classy yeah yeah
on top of the computers you know I was
14 at the time so I I should say that um
but um but yeah I mean look it was
always around that I was always either
dealing with uh music or I was dealing
with computers and I couldn't really
pick so so when I got lucky enough to
have the option of like deciding what I
wanted to do uh in my life I had a
successful company that I was able to
sell before Spotify and that
meant that I didn't have to sort of
immediately go and find out what I
wanted to do I I knew I wanted to do
music and I wanted to do technology but
um you know to set the scene the music
industry was going right like this and
everyone told me this is a horrible
thing you can never make money in this
thing it's never going to be a big
business please don't do that go and do
something else instead but that was my
passion I know but Daniel how cool is it
that you got to combine your passions
and make money doing it and be a success
so that's a 22 that was your dream is
you sit here at 40
um you're still still really young in
the world what's your dream now at 40.
well my my dream is
um really to build I I feel like we're
we're still early in this journey on
Spotify and and the amazing thing is we
get to deal with some of the most
creative uh and inspirational humans on
the planet right and
um whether you're just starting out or
whether you're already established if we
can build like the best place for those
creators
um where they can grow Their audience
where they can engage with their fans
and monetize it I really believe that
those storytellers that um those
Educators those artists
um those are are the people that will
make people feel things will make people
grow and and learn and develop
themselves and if we can be that place
where people get inspired and grow as
human beings but also have
help these amazing creative storytellers
that's a pretty amazing thing to
contribute to the world